[Musique]
il ya encore peu de temps
j'imaginais la culture comme un lieu
sacré et réserver un endroit où se
dérégler des cérémonies des événements
et même des manifestations une entité
qui faisait appel à ceux qui savent où
ceux qui on avait le droit
aujourd'hui ma vision est totalement
différente car loin d'être réservés
la culture est vivante et continuera de
vivre tant que nous continuerons de la
partager et le plus bel aspect de tout
ça était son incroyable pouvoir car
effectivement la culture à ce pouvoir de
guérir de nous élever pour moi tout a
commencé en 2016
j'ai eu la chance se départir à
l'étranger à montréal au canada
je suis resté quatre ans pour faire mes
études en architecture de paysage en
horticulture et jardinerie
c'était quatre années magnifiques
c'était une autre vie une vie d'étudiant
avec une ville et tous ces stimuli qui
peuvent exister mais un jour c'était le
temps de rentrer c'était en 2016 et
c'est là pour moi j'ai ressenti pour la
première fois quelque chose de lourd sur
les épaules
c'était mon premier rêve est très sec
très brutal retour au fresnoy
après quatre ans passés à l'étranger
dans un autre environnement
après un bon dîner de retrouvailles avec
ma famille mes amis je me retrouve dans
la chambre l'adolescent que j'avais
laissé il ya quatre ans où rien n'avait
changé et tout commençait à tourner dans
ma tête
pourquoi comment qu'est ce qui s'est
passé à cela s'ajoutait une déception
sentimentale
parce qu'en quittant le canada j'ai dû
quitter un petit ami de l'époque la
crise du quart du siècle la petite
claque des 25 ans j'étais un peu perdu
vraiment je me sentais mal fabien vous
prenez le tout une secoué pendant un
moment et ça me donne une belle grosse
déprime une période noire sans couleur
sans couleur sans sable j'étais en
souffrance
j'étais malade je voulais sortir de
cette période
si vous voulez en guérir ma famille mes
amis les plus proches ont tout essayé
mais il n'y a presque pas arrivé sans
fin jour où recrutement des primes une
demi soeur ne pouvait plus et m'a forcé
à la suivre à une répétition de danse
2010 cette direction motu uta
vous connaissez quelques vies
parmi une soixantaine de personnes
des fois ça va je vous connaissais
quelques
femme une soixantaine de personnes et au
bout de quelques minutes ce qui semblait
être orchestre commençait à s'installer
et c'est là que tout a commencé sans
savoir
j'étais sur le point d'assister pour moi
un des plus belles expressions de notre
culture
le mba
l'appétit
avaient lieu deux à trois fois par
semaine au minimum il y avait deux
heures de travail deux heures de
pratique le tout pendant six mois
notre chef de troupe de parler quand
haïtien ce qui m'a permis inconsciemment
d'apprécier et de comprendre notre
culture de comprendre pourquoi ans dans
c est sûr qu allons danser à ce rythme
là j'étais très occupé et mon esprit
commencé à se sentir beaucoup mieux
effectivement j'ai commencé
tranquillement emprunter ce chemin celui
de la guérison qui pour moi a commencé
avec ce monde celui du ori tahiti cette
noirceur commençait à s'effacer car le
hamas est bien plus que des répétitions
c'est une famille une fraternité plus
d'une centaine de personnes ce soutien
s'appuie partage échange des liens se
créent mais un métier et bien plus
encore après ça tout est vite passé je
me tourne le soir du 11 juillet à to'ata
excité moi qui étais un piètre danseur
qui n'avaient jamais fait de partis de
toute ma vie
un outil qui veut dire littéralement
ciseaux qui est un mouvement des jeunes
aux plus particulièrement des hanches
très simple comme ça je l'avais jamais
fait et pourtant je me retrouver là à
quelques mètres de la scène de to'ata
opposition top1 avec les prêts des
percussions qui retentissaient en moi si
fort toutes ces heures de travail
les cris les joies et douleurs tout
augmenter au même moment je sens que
cette énergie qui brouillait dans les
pieds qui veut monter le long de mon
corps et qui petit à petit s'est élevée
au dessus de moi
c'était pour moi la première fois que je
faisais l'expérience du moine cette si
précieuse énergie qui fait partie d'un
autre polynésie elle venait de me bénir
de la plus belle des façons
on me faisait me sentir vivant le pays
bas était devenu mon temps mon univers à
moi un endroit sacré j'allais piémont
ressources et vous me guérir les chez
mes blessures et reprendre confiance en
moi avec cette famille j'ai pu
comprendre que j'avais avant la tenir
une place
j'étais vraiment sur le chemin de la
guérison
la maladie était loin derrière moi mais
après la réunion c'est le gros calme
plus aucune répétition on se retrouve
presque un peu tout seul
j'allais beaucoup mieux j'étais guérie
j'avais soif
j'avais faim je voulais encore apprendre
je voulais encore m'instruire je voulais
encore goûté à cette si belle chose que
l'on appelle la culture ce qui m'a fait
revenir un petit pont l'arrière au
niveau de ma réflexion cave au canada
avant de quitter montréal
je ne sais plus vraiment dans quelle
circonstance je me suis retrouvé avec
une machine de tatouage dans les mains
et ce qui devait arriver avec moi je me
suis tatoué le pied vous pouvez vraiment
c'était un test et je n'y connaissais
strictement rien mais pourtant ça
m'était étrangement familier ce monde-là
du tatouage
j'ai vraiment décidé de me concentrer
dessus parce qu'on a trop dit depuis ma
jeunesse
florent il faut que tu fasses ce que tu
es j'ai fais ok je vais tatoué mais ce
n'est pas aussi facile que ça au final
tout a changé ou millénale en 2017
lorsque pareil toujours géré la sauveuse
une demi soeur m'a inscrit un peu
secrètement un festival de tatouages qui
se donnait à la mairie de phare enfin
nous oui à toutes et à tous c'était pour
moi une énorme première marche
un premier pas très grand qui m'a permis
de me mais j'ai totalement dans ce
monde-là du tatouage
j'ai pu voir et être vu j'ai pu
rencontrer d'autres tatoueur les plus
jeunes comme moi qui ai commencé comme
des anciens qui avaient plusieurs
dizaines d'années d'expérience et là je
commencer tranquillement à nourrir cette
fin cette soif justement de
connaissances et j'avais toujours autant
envie de me rapprocher de cette culture
j'ai continué un peu dans mon coin à
m'instruire m'éduquer sur notamment les
motifs que nous possédons et je trouvais
très intéressant le fait que chaque
archipel chaque grand bassin de
population avait son propre langage ses
propres motifs sa propre façon de
raconter une histoire
sinon continuez dans mon coin pendant
des années une et demie aujourd'hui
c'est devenu mon métier d'une passion
j'ai réussi à faire le transfert de ma
passion un métier et je trouve ça
vraiment magnifique
j'ai pu le faire grâce à l'aide de ceux
qui m'ont aidé ceux qui m'ont fait
confiance ceux qui m'ont soutenu à ce
moment là j'étais vraiment plus malade
du tout j'étais guérie totalement et ça
tombait bien parce que le deuxième mois
le deuxième est il va arriver à grands
pas et j'avais hâte de goûter à cette
expérience en tant que quelqu un jeudi
normal qui n'est pas en souffrance
et c'est là où j'ai compris que la
culture ne vais pas que vous guérir vous
élève littéralement au point du
spirituel comme psychique et lors de ce
2ème riva j'ai rencontré une personne
formidable qui aujourd'hui fait partie
de ma vie au quotidien avec cette
personne je partage tout avec cette
personne
je suis en train de fonder une famille
tout est allé vite vraiment très très
vite et que ce soit la culture du côté
du monde du ori tahiti ou de celui du
tatouage
ça a été mais deux sauvetages
aujourd'hui je vais vraiment mieux et en
regardant d'où je viens et le chemin que
j'ai emprunté
je voulais vous partager ce que j'avais
connu que la culture était un magnifique
moyen de se guérir de s'élever car
effectivement d'une déprime noir sans
odeur sans couleur sans saveur
la culture m'a pris et il ajoutait plus
haut que les nuages a voulu un peu me
rapprocher du soleil pour montrer que
regarde autour de toi c'est un monde qui
est beau c'est un monde en lumière
n'oubliez pas que ça soit pour vous
guérir ou simplement pour vous élever la
culture sera là la culture est là pour
tous elle est présente sous différents
aspects que ça soit la langue les
légendes les aude hérault qui s'assoit
la danse et ça sera le tatouage ou
simplement notre façon de vivre la
culture sera toujours là haut pour vous
aider merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]